vous venez pas tu prend combien est
litres
un litre c'est du baratin de la
gourmandise non là je vous assure je
vous fais pas le boniment même un petit
peu non un litre c'est la quantité
réglementaire maintenant s'il vous plaît
je vous en supplie des mois je vous
assure on a besoin de vous les gars ya
tellement peu de gens qui passent ici
j'ai pas arrivé à faire mon quota mais
aujourd'hui je préfère quand vous me
parlez plus gentiment pas ce que je vais
vous expliquer une chose pour moi c'est
la première fois ci vous dire moi aussi
c'est la première fois que ça vous
effraie pas j'espère au contraire je
trouve ça plutôt sympathique
c'est vrai la première fois les gens
sont souvent nerveux contracter il pense
que ça fait mal et tourner de l'oeil
tombe dans les pommes vous inquiétez pas
s'il y en a un des deux qui tombe dans
les pommes ce sera vous peut-être de
bonne humeur ah non monsieur je vous
rassure tout de suite il n'y a personne
qui va tomber dans les pommes
marc dieu vous allez vous décontracter
vous allonger et quand vous êtes prêts
moi j'y vais je me décontracte quand
vous êtes prêt de givet qu'accor vous
êtes prêt gmail bien avant bien sûr une
chose le garrot
alors parce que vous strangulation on
est obligé ces mêmes conseillers sinon
risque d accident
oui il faut il faut que ça gonfle
pourquoi vous faites ça mais pourrait
pour aider des millions de gens vous
pouvez pas imaginer si si si je vous
assure quelques minutes ensemble et ces
vies humaines de sauver ouais bon
n'exagérons rien s'il suffisait d'aller
voir une dame pour tous qui est le
problème et puis quand on y va vous êtes
d'accord bon d'accord on y va là bas
c'est dans le camion
en fait ça dans un camion oui il ya dans
la remorque
j'ai pas faire votre prélèvements sur le
trottoir allez allez je vous rejoins en
or non mais franchement on va falloir
finir faire les [ __ ] pourra obtenir le
globule frêche